A monogamy, or a relationship with one person, is actually very rare among mammals.
With just about 3% showing monogamous relationships.
So what happens to people?
Is it really better to be with one person for a lifetime?
Historically, people did not practice monogamy.
Anthropological notes indicate that they were tens of thousands of years old
about 85% of human societies were composed of men with more than one partner
The reason why most of the world turned into socially imposed monogamy was debated among scientists,
but the leading hypothesis is to reduce the risk of sexually transmitted infections.
As human societies changed about small collector hunters
in large densely populated agricultural societies,
models show that changing lifestyles would allow sexually transmitted infections to spread by causing death and infertility.
But while monogamy may have evolved to prevent sexually transmitted infections, what is it now?
Many claim they are in a monogamous relationship, but in fact they commit adultery.
Estimates of cheating among married Americans ranged from 21% -57% among men,
and 11% -35% among women.
In fact, studies on students in relationships
showed that 1 out of 5 acknowledges the use of Tinder on the side,
and those who identify themselves as monogamous are less likely to practice safe sex, including using condoms and testing for sexually transmitted infections.
Because they are afraid that the representation of these customs will make them doubt.
However, they are more likely to use condoms for both vaginal and anal intercourse,
to be regularly tested for sexually transmitted infections, and discuss external sexual relations with their primary partners.
So, now it seems that they are in consensual non-interlinked relationships, at a lower risk of sexually transmitted infections than those in monogamous relationships.
Research using 1500 people in monogamous relationships
and 617 people in consensual non-ethnical relationships
did not show any significant differences in the function of the relationship, generality of satisfaction, dedication, and passionate love.
In fact, the jealousy was lower and more confident in individuals who are not monogamous.
Skeptical to these results?
You're not the only one.
The survey gave the participants an opportunity to read a brief description of the hypothetical results of the research
in which it says: "Generally, polymer pairs had more positive outcomes than monogamous pairs."
The participants rated this statement as unfairly prejudicial.
And when exactly the same statement was replaced in favor of monogamous connections
it would have been rated less unfair.
These results help us to show that we are prepared to think that they are monogamous connections
more loving, committed, and satisfying.
While consensual unconnected bonds such as palliamy and open connections are more often seen in negative light.
This does not mean that your partner and you need to think about other people.
The monogamy might be for some, but also not for some.
One study showed that men and women who wanted to get involved in random sex,
were more likely to have higher levels of testosterone,
but this group is still a minority.
In self-identifiable research on the ideal arrangement of the connection
It has been shown that both men and women predominantly prefer a strictly monogamous arrangement of the connection when asked to choose.
So, if you prefer to keep your relationship for one person or more
Research has shown that there are many ways to have a dedicated, satisfying, and loving relationship,
and monogamy is not the only gold standard.
Thank you very much for watching.
If you have not seen it yet, we just released another new video about what happens when Millennials are trying to be environmentalists.
It's a new style of video.
We tried to make science fun and cool, so watch and share the video.
It would mean a lot to us.
You can click this link here, and we'll link in the description of the video.
Also subscribe.
There will be a new video on Thursday.
So, hi. And see you!